welcome back to pooh detective tonight's
investigation the case of the Pringles
can of crap an Ohio defense attorney
named Jake Jack blakesley was suspended
last week after leaving a poop filled
Pringles can outside a Victim Advocacy
Center back in
2021 he also had to lay out a few
hundred bucks for a case of fze blak Lee
also pleaded guilty to disorderly
conduct charge and paid only 248 bucks
in fines and court costs the fine was
because the victims actually loved what
they thought was a new
flavor oh he reportedly tried to play
off the can of poop as a prank and even
admitted he had done this at least 10
other times in the
past now we don't know if he put the
crap in the can by hand or if he you
know went right for it but here's how I
imagine he did it
see you perhaps it's easy to hit the
target if you focus I don't know but
thank you Jean for drawing that
[Applause]
just going to leave that up there
anyway you know who solved the case of
the Pringles poop believe it or not they
have an entire force devoted to solving
such
crimes stupid joke but it's funny Emily
uh it's probably the best time to ask
what is your favorite flavor of Pringles
I haven't had Pringles in forever but
that one the original one if you take
the two chips on the top and the bottom
you look like a duck you like put it on
your mouth like that that's like as far
as my Pringles experience goes but by
the way that picture that Jean Drew
impeccable job that's exactly how I
envisioned he did it too but my my
question is like this guy woke up he's
like I'm going to be a menace to society
today Let me poop in a can throw it out
the window in multiple locations and you
know what that's that's my way of like
ruining this Earth a little bit see
that's not the part that bothers me no
no and then the part that bothers me is
that like when people were like
suspending him were they thinking about
how this guy did it what went into it
you have to be a sick crazy evil person
to do that and then best part you could
have gotten away with it easily just go
to San Francisco and do it there and
nobody will know the difference you can
it what do you think that that that's
none of that's the part that bothers me
the act the the okay he shouldn't have
gotten in trouble but he should be
disbarred not for the pooping but
because he admitted to doing it 10 times
yes what kind of lawyer are you
exactly you don't get caught rule number
one's you don't get caught rule number
two is if you do get caught it only
happened that one time and you hated it
and you would never do it again exactly
you're already a lawyer yep thank you
thank you Jimmy I don't know if you
remember this but do you remember when
snack chips introduced olestra in the
bake chips and the side effect was anal
leakage do you think maybe Pringles has
just solved the problem by having the
chips come in a can that you can use
afterwards as it turns out pooping in a
Pringles can is a gateway drug because
once you pop you can't stop you know
what I mean but you know what's funny
about that that you took it back because
here's another thing to get upset about
yeah get Pringles material I'm not
scared of you people okay so here it is
okay he was leaving them specifically at
the same place yeah which was an
advocacy group for Crime Victims haven't
these people been through enough without
getting a Pringles can like you know
something it this was an obsession of
his yeah a cereal pooper yeah cereal
pooper
he je Jeffrey bomber I I uh I uh I timed
the poop stories for when you're here
yeah I know you
did oh I don't think you could ever do
that no no but I I could pretty sure I
could stuff you in a Pringles K boom
boom take that listen take that this is
this I'm glad he's disar okay he
shouldn't be no but only for a year but
cuz he's a yeah this is a stupid
crime even if you left it with regular
chips most people aren't going to step
out and be like food on the ground let
me pick it up yeah so they just walked
by it that's why he did it 10 times like
he this kid isn't this is not an this is
not he's not breaking the mold with
these evil villain plans when I was
grown up as a kid you took dog stuff put
it in the bag you lit it on fire so when
they lady came out Miss pivus sorry when
the lady came out they stopped it cuz
they had to put the fire out and then
the the extra thing is then ha there's
there woohoo got you he took off running
this is putting in the bag and
like M haa and they're going oh this is
trash damn it do it again so he's a
horrible the only thing he's going for
him he's the one lawyer that isn't full
of but other than that he's terrible and
there you go bang up next he's known for
Gotti looks and now for writing books
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else